hallo hier wunderschön wenn ich hier
wieder einmal waren und willkommen zu
einem neuen nicht gesponserten video
hatte gibt es ein test hält klar bruder
alte mania wie sie hier gerade
stattfindet ich weiß ich hab es schon
eine million mal erwähnt aber ich habe
65 tage lang sport gemacht
ich habe 65 tage sport gemacht
es ist zwar wieder über drei wochen hier
es sollte mal wieder anfangen dann bin
ich meinen somebody nicht verliere aber
ins öl mein gewicht zu halten habe ich
nicht verloren aber das interesse an der
welt der nicht frech werke waren klar
weil sind wir mal ganz ehrlich versuche
gerade ein intro gespräch mit euch zu
führen aber wir wollen die süßigkeiten
sehen ihr habt sind titel gelesen
süßigkeiten ohne zucker schacht befreien
ich habe eine box voll mit süßigkeiten
ohne zucker und die werden wir heute
testen das einzige was ich ohne zucker
kenne sind kaum
[Musik]
sie haben schon gewonnen hat wenn ich
hatte mir dafür die sachen bestellt aber
die box ist proppevoll
also lasst uns loslegen ich habe noch
kein frühstück gegessen
seit mal hier wie träumen leben ist dass
ich sie sich kein symbol dessen kann ok
produkt nummer eins unter freiheit
schaum warf helgoländer toll super toll
warum ich das so krass finde ist dass
ich dachte das ist einfach zucker
schauen da drin
und wie kann das zuckerfrei seien drei
dicke schaum war für den zuckerfrei mit
kakao klausur mit süßungsmittel mike
molly malt sirup michael sirup kann bei
übermäßigem verzehr abführend wirken
das ist eine waffel mit schaum
marshmallow creme und schokolade an den
seiten eine sonde das land 91 kalorien
[Musik]
wie im mittelalter das schmeckt jetzt
nicht krass süß aber es schmeckt auch
nicht wien zur kasse hat sich die
gleichen produkte noch mal mit zucker
kaufen soll und welchen direkten
vergleich zu haben aber stiftung
warentest stabil nächstes produkt wo
mein gott ja wer das original
may ist einfach verbrannter zucker
karamell ist eine durch starkes
trockenes erhitzen erzeugte mischung aus
geschmolzenem zucker seinen oxidierten
und kondensierten reaktionsprodukte
wieso können wert us-original zuckerfrei
sein so kommt und bonbons zu sehen dass
wir einfach kein zucker drin ein stück
hat somit neun kalorie zieht ganz normal
aus ich habe viel mehr damit gerechnet
dass sich das sofort raus schmeckt und
sagen so um dass es kein zucker geht
voll klar obwohl die hauptzutat dieses
isomalt ist ich bin erst mit euch ich
bin ein bisschen schockiert ich wollte
nicht beschweren wollte sagen aber
schmeckt nicht
ich bin mir nicht so sicher es ist
wahrscheinlich so ungesund ständig
süßungsmittel zuerst aber bin überrascht
wie gut das schmeckt beiden produkten
stand bisher kann bei übermäßigem
verzehr abführend wirken gucken was am
ende dieses videos passiert ja wer das
original zuckerfrei ist okay kann man es
kaufen kann man genießen
super als nächstes haben wir zuckerfrei
schoko cookies mit schokoladenstückchen
kann bei übermäßigem verzehr abführend
wirken also hier sind gleich drei
süßungsmittel drin multijet ried und ihr
sohn mal ja das ist ein bisschen ich mal
am ende des tages praktisch selber
cookies und macht kein zucker rein aber
darum sollte er hier nicht gehen
hawkins bestehen doch nur aus zucker
butter und mehl immer wenn man gucke ich
selber macht sind dass die drei
hauptzutaten haben sie es geschafft den
zucker zu ersetzen
das sind jetzt nicht die leckersten
kekse die ich jemals gegessen habe sie
gehen klar papierfähnchen stadtplatz
richtig grün blauen verdienen die
innereien sind papier statt plastik
stabile kekse kann man sagen zu instabil
juni besser ohne zuckersüßes fruchtgummi
zuckerfrei mit süßungsmitteln gesichter
das unter allgemein unser land ihn nicht
legal aber schon das projekt und das ist
doch unglaublich das ist eine stabile
süßigkeit also man frist eigentlich
hauptsächlich dieses mal zieht das
besteht einfach auch mal tief und dann
noch ein paar andere sachen dazu
getroffen und wie macht mir das ein
bisschen angst
aber nicht allen schmeckt auf jeden fall
ich möchte auf jeden fall sehr gut sind
stabile gummibärchen kommen sollte wir
hatten lange keine kekse mehr coppenrath
mit era hat auf jeden fall noch mehr er
oder zuckerfrei butterkeks auf dem
butterkeks steht ganz fett zucker frei
war man butter personen extrem
backpulver geschmack doch die könnte ich
mich gewöhnt nach haben wir hierfür
mittel drin meinte isolator die tröte
retreat und in wie viel eigentlich mal
so auf einer packung drauf steht was man
nicht kennt ja stabil
stabile kekse diese coppenrath bringen
falls die zuckerfreie kekse essen wollte
wir haben nochmal gummibärchen wort
glauben wird gespannt hilfen also von
einer anderen bekannten marke sind die
kirche nicht so zusammen ich bin jetzt
nicht so wohl aus also die original
ersetzen sie nicht aber der durchmacht
ist schon okay sind schwer zu sagen
meint ohne zucker aber dafür mit martin
h das original ist einfach und so viel
besser nicht fair ist zu sagen dass das
hier ein toller ersatz ist definitiv
okay leute aber wisst ihr was nicht
wahnsinnig gemacht haben - ohne zucker
musste doch nützen aber wir wissen das
und insel martha s ersetzen kann
die konsistenz haben sie nicht so
hingekriegt der sieht okay aus so ein
bisschen schmeckt nach meldung ganz im
hinteren eck stübchen schmeckt man
marsch meldung aber nein vielleicht wenn
du aus gesundheitlichen gründen kein
zucker essen da warum auch immer dann
ist es leichter satz ab ich hole keine
zuckerpreis die hier nicht auch noch ein
bisschen
die haben es noch in den mainstream
markt geschafft die sugar free corny
riegel wurde paar schafe ohne
konservierungsstoffe ohne zusatz von
konservierungsstoffen laut gesetz soll
das heißen also laut gesetz haben wir
keine konservierungsstoffe reingemacht
auch so krass ist dieses mal dass bis
dann auch die hauptzutat damit man
erstmal mit kette menge meinte ich meine
leute schaut euch mal diesen riegel an
und dann steht da als erste zutat malt
die erste zutat wäre doch vielleicht
manche weißen kugel oder weiß ich nie
sein erstens brauchen wir eine fette
ladung meint und dann gerichtete
vollkorngetreide blocken bin komplett
verwirrt warum man die ersten zwei
drittel ist die haut mich jetzt nicht um
ist aber auch nicht täglich hat aber so
einen komischen nachgeschmack denn die
die partie schon gegessen seitdem großer
freund wird von schreibt das meer in die
kommentare leute und vergesst nicht dem
video einen damm und geben vor er will
nur ein keks essen muss kaum ein kita -
wie das anbringen
wir mussten früher für die schule immer
kekse backen meine mutter hat immer
diese wiener sand ringe gekauft und die
einfach in schokolade getunkt und basel
nüssel drüber gemacht und hatte mal
gesagt sie waren selbst gebaut mit
seiner live act hierfür müssen größer
sein das ist jetzt sehr unbefriedigend
wenn die nicht eigentlich auch hinein so
groß so wie das andere zu befreien
die überzeugen mich komplett würde auch
niemals vermuten an die sind recht
schleppend mit ehre
wir haben uns aber für etwas naschen in
maßen kann bei übermäßigem verzehr ab
circa fünf häschen abführend wirken als
wären sie zuckerersatz naja hier ist
cool dieses vegan mein kühlschrank
als meine schnauze haben die fruchtigen
schauen mit coenzym q10 aloe vera beauty
ein beauty häschen so und jetzt
abführmittel man wenn man mal schnell
ein apfel mittel brauchen würde ich es
kaufen unser letztes produkt ist einfach
iconic es wird gefragt zuckerfreie es
sind wirklich ein traum was ist da drin
meint vielleicht die solar und martin
sirup kann bei übermäßigem verzehr am 5
er ist seit neuem stunde amt für mittel
die müssen das büro zuckerfreien im zwei
frische leute zuckerfreie in dem zwei
jahren auf jeden fall gewonnen ja sogar
einem 2 sa so und jetzt wollen wir mal
schauen wie lange der abführenden effekt
braucht es der eintritt
ich habe keine lust mit durchfall wenn
er noch kommt gebe ich euch bescheid das
ist ja auch ein medizinischer test also
falls irgendetwas jetzt mit mir passiert
zum werber werde oder so sage ich euch
auf jeden fall bescheid ansonsten wir
endlich das video jetzt ich hoffe ich
habe das video gefallen und ich hab euch
das video gefallen und wenn ja dann gibt
es mir einfach nach oben und wenn nein
dann schadet ansonsten sehen wir uns
beim nächsten video ich werde es wie ein
versuchskaninchen hier liegen und auf
meinen tod warten und durch weil ich
hoffe du kommst nicht als super denn ich
hab keine los auf durch bei denn
zuckerfreie sachen können abführen
würden
das nervt mich so und deswegen sogar
freie sachen auch doch nicht zum
abnehmen gut weil er es so kein zweites
länder durch warum haben wir uns gut
fühle mich nicht schlecht